husky tourner un autre film comique à
rome aurait pu avoir peur de passer du
rire aux larmes
c'est ça en principe oui mais en fait un
acteur peut jouer n'importe quel rôle un
coluche c'est pas moi non plus j'ai joué
longtemps et personne ne s'en est aperçu
alors maintenant que je joue autre chose
on dit ah bah tiens finalement coluche
c'était un personnage
et puis lambert dans tchao pantin pas
sonné au un autre et puis maintenant je
fais le roi dagobert
c'est encore un autre c'est pas moi non
pur le roi dagobert ça pose aucun
problème à personne sauf quelques fois
au public qui qui qui va pas voir des
films comiques de quelqu'un qui ne l'est
pas ou qui va pas voir les films
tragique de quelqu'un qui comme ça ça
peut arriver
enfin moi je prends surtout c'est que ça
arrive qu'on les films sont ratés quoi à
celle qu'ont les fines sont bons ils
peuvent être dramatique ou comique qui
en fait c'est là il s'agit de la même
chose
il s'agit de faire du spectacle est de
distraire et le comique le dramatique
c'est la même chose à faire il s'agit de
faire semblant de faire quelque chose
quoi quand on l'ancien comité
café-théâtre l'infini filet cinéma ça me
plaît bien mais j'aimerais bien
continuer un peu mais en fait c'est pas
moi qui décide c'est les gens qui vont
au cinéma